alarms there's the ones that wake you up
in the morning
tell you you've got a message that your
lunch is ready to close the fridge door
emails phone calls skype calls facebook
message turbulence
[Music]
and one particular researcher has
created this
an alarm to stand out from the crowd
an alarm to stop a head-on car collision
her name is i'm carol baldwin and she's
i am the director of the human factors
and applied cognition program at george
mason university so how do you go about
creating one of the world's most
annoying sounds we
started out by going out and getting
recordings of actual sounds that were in
automobiles currently then we
took those sounds back to the lab once
they collected the sounds it was time to
test on people they created a system
where the listener could play a sound
and then put it in a category that the
sound most represented
either a low urgency like a facebook
notification a medium range urgency like
a check engine alert and finally a high
level urgency like an oncoming collision
warning
and then from there we set up a series
of driving simulator studies and they're
driving along and they're doing a
another task just to kind of give them a
distraction component and then suddenly
unexpectedly car that they're following
would break suddenly and we looked at
their
collision avoidance response on the
timing of that they created the perfect
forward collision warning alarm and this
was really important because we found
that the sounds being used currently
weren't perceived as being very urgent
you know a poorly designed sound can be
more dangerous than not having a warning
at all
so thanks for using the most annoying
sound to keep us safe
you